I will mix and we're cups played
BuzzFeed's truth or wine so first what's
your new single breakup song written
about somebody in particular actually
was we ended up writing a lot like
greatly up songs yeah so do I not get to
sip my Chardonnay not yet huh
okay then which songs of yours are you
the most tired of performing only yeah
Jerry you're not done without one when
it's in the setlist oh yeah the truth
just comes out like word from it I was
saying the other day like when we sing
secret love song I absolutely adore it
and it's like one of my favorite things
to perform but if I'm unwell
it's the worst experience of my life
does anyone else feel like that like
when your name best for money in secret
love songs in the setlist
I'm thinking lord give me strength I
can't I just can't
well I literally get anxious every time
before that song comes up every time
here but weirdly like way nice or first
of a single I never tire of that I still
love it with bangs but it's so energetic
I'm literally sweating me tip oh nice
Rian's like the life out of this while
I'm doing it and then I'm 12 did all the
dance free and then I get on the floor
and do that point where I would
literally I'd get on the floor that was
the one I look forward to the least like
I literally despise that I don't know
why I think I'm actually intense for
real yeah I feel I still do a lot of the
time I'm like on salute again I do love
it that's a six on my life for four
minutes like you say it's so intense so
maybe it's the choreo a lot of the time
okay so we logged a lot of those answers
are just of screaming lazy as fudge yeah
basically when fans called you
underrated in the states do you agree do
you think I deserve more love from
America does anybody else think Jessie
sounds like a Dalek word she's saying
why don't you have Wi-Fi bib get on the
Wi-Fi honestly you sound like an actual
robot it's so funny like I can hear when
is lm6 coming has an album title been
decided obviously a hundred percent
coming because we are currently partying
and recorded it but we've already
written it so we were recording it until
lockdown happened and I'm going to have
to sip my drink I can't tell you what
the title is but there is title a hint
because it'll just give it away I wasn't
gonna say it's a party yeah celebration
okay that's all you get in what was the
last thing you sent in your group trip
is pretty pride that I suppose was
stubborn or creature on escape okay do
you still like the name little mix if
you could rename the group what would
you pick oh wow I love the night now I
we are through a lot and personally all
tasted it when we first got it because
we were so in love with rythmics
and they took the song to like love the
name but now I love it because I think
that is kind of like make everyone still
think that we're really young when
actually I'm lucky 38
yeah degree I really did not like the
name such a long time and I wouldn't say
I'm like still like the biggest fan of
Little Mix but I feel like with every
name it just becomes like you do
everything anymore do you like it's just
aa name so yeah
if he's like it's given us like a lot of
longevity in the music industry yeah I'm
quite grateful for it now yeah and I
can't imagine us called anything else if
I'm honest no name I wouldn't I would
just say no well Little Mix I suppose
you know I would say what place no I say
anime quite like that name it's same
yeah man like other banks have you
written any songs whilst social distance
hmm I haven't side write in yet no I've
written a cleric ideas down like I feel
like I whenever I go to bed I always end
up like thinking like lyrics I like
poems and stuff that I write down any
norm
I don't like brought them into fruition
yet yes I feel like it's because we've
actually got the album though as well
I'm so glad it's finished and it just
needs some touching up Finster was there
ever a time you were close to disbanding
what is what's a disability what's that
word sesh why am I in charge of reading
the questions when I'm yeah well not
yeah yeah I don't think we've ever ever
ever had a conversation about no drinks
I'll drink to that
has there been any offers for any of you
to call Sorrell I love how much they're
trying to get out of us at this Aussie
the answer no no no no not that we're
aware of
I'm sure yeah anyone actually I did get
offered a really big how many of you
ever thought of releasing solo music
you have its little hands none of us
have ever wanted to do that who how
would we have the time first no no my
full-time job I do think there would be
a time when we will eventually do our
solo projects but I think we're always
come back together as little bees in the
new future yeah yeah will there be any
features on lm6
this is a hard one because we know that
there will they're not set in stone so
we can't technically see yes but we do
know that there is going to be a few all
right that's right then are there any
past collaborations you've done that you
would say no to today oh good question
yeah oh yeah one for me yeah so we all
have a sip chessmen they have a sip just
like la yeah yeah oh you know I'm gonna
something else oh really
maybe just message in a group chat later
all right okay
have you ever slid into a fan stems all
the time yeah I like trying to get with
them kind of thing oh no no no imagine
no absolutely no did you ever feel
rivalry with fifth harmony never like
dude like them as people but it was a
point where we did not rivalry but like
I can't hear a damn thing is that just
me or is that everyone I think what she
was trying to say let me translate it
see if I've got it in you nod
there wasn't rivalry as such because we
loved them all and we did like fifth
harmony but do you mean when they came
out we were below I don't know yeah yeah
I don't think it was a rivalry because
they were so different I think if they
were doing the same stuff we were doing
and we were similar I don't know but I
feel like we never really thought there
was rivalry between us I think if actual
girls had a problem with the girls I
think it was more just a bit oh I
thought we were on the same level
yeah can I just say these questions are
absolute savage and whoever came up with
them I mean I'm kind of living for it
because I love it what is your favorite
X Factor performance super bang went
back to performing I was gonna say 80
performances yeah like from being on The
X Factor et et was so sick don't let go
hello that changed it for us I mean guys
were really blown our own trumpets were
mentioned in every performance who had
the worst style of The X Factor he's
served to say all of us we were all
tragic yeah I think me and Perry get
impact outside the hotel and I was
probably the lowest of the low in terms
of my fashion sense but you know I
thought no I'm gonna look back at that
timing think oh my god what a little
troll I think I was happy I was so happy
we were all so content and none of us
give about what anyone thought we did in
a hair we'd rock our onesies or we'd
rock like these horrendous outfits and
not even think anything of it we didn't
kind of did we okay who has improved the
most with choreo since X Factor is going
to be made surely yeah oh yeah I see you
definitely yeah I I absolutely despised
dancing remember oh yeah
I don't have to set up with a punishment
in the first few years and I was like
just FYI if we have to keep dancing I
don't think I can be in this group
anymore tomorrow but cries don't you
Bullock is all to do a confidence though
a lot of there yeah because I'm a little
bit I danced in college and I loved it
and then as soon as it got like serious
and we had to do serious career I was
like this is not what I want right now
like I hate it I mean look at us now
favorite and least favorite song from
like a whole ever collection of music oh
wow favorite would be shout out today
it's just because it's one of the first
operate as a group we were like oh and
then my least favorite black magic
really hello it's mad
I think my favorite is show out burp I'm
gonna have to sit to the one out because
I actually despise one of our songs Wow
I know you're gonna I think you'll agree
especially but I'm gonna sit because hey
yeah if I say Sony does that make ring a
bell
yes okay yeah that one so I can't reveal
the song because it's it has a feature
and I don't want to seem mean but the
song makes me like that's be fair the
feature makes it fun anyway favorite
touch I was a sense of the other day and
I thinking oh my gosh this is such a
change yeah um least favorite we are who
we are
you always loved that one nah not me Oh
from DNA no we'd always be together
that song oh my god absolutely no no no
greater love something and you'd be like
oh yeah such an idiot what is she gonna
say say I don't say wasn't that bad Oh
something about like what music he likes
no chance yeah I'm pretty sure that
makes it make the girl in that okay
thank you so much for speeding everyone
for your very saucy questions I hope you
guys are loving our brand new single
great of songs I thank you so I hope
just give me a bit of entertainment
whilst in lockdown and you hope you love
you guys lots easy love you guys
[Music]